I
welcome to today's lecture by gretchen
morgenson absence of accountability for
the 2008 financial crisis my name is
david bob i serve as director of the LNP
Kirby jr. center for constitutional
studies and citizenship of Hillsdale
College today's lecture made possible by
a generous gift from Hillsdale College
Alumni Sarah and Chris shkola is part of
a monthly lecture series that addresses
significant and timely political
historical and economic topics from a
constitutional perspective the kirby
center marks an extension of Hillsdale
college's commitment to teaching the
Constitution through teaching the
enduring principles of the Declaration
and the Constitution the kirby center
seeks to inspire citizens that is
students teachers policymakers and
elected officials to return those
principles to their central place in
American public life you may find out
more about our programs online at the
kirby center org and also via Facebook
and Twitter if you are viewing this
lecture online at the kirby center
webcast or via c-span's livestream you
may submit a question for today's
speaker by emailing us at Kirby lecture
at Hillsdale edu I will now ask
hillsdale college senior Bailey Jones to
introduce our speaker an English and
political economy double major at
Hillsdale College Bailey is completing
an internship with the kirby center here
this summer as part of the Washington
Hillsdale internship program which for
40 years has sent our undergraduate
students to Washington for what we like
to joke is a study abroad program Bailey
gretchen morgenson is the assistant
business and financial editor at The New
York Times in 2002 she received the
pulitzer prize for her coverage of wall
street prior to joining the times in
1998 she worked as the assistant
managing editor at phors magazine and as
the executive editor of worth magazine
she is also authored or co-authored
several books including Forbes great
minds of business and reckless
endangerment she received her ba in
english from st. olaf college today ms
morganson will be speaking on the topic
the absence of accountability for the
2008 financial crisis please join me in
welcoming miss Gretchen Morgenson thank
you so much Bailey and David it's really
joy for me to be here at the kirby
center today and to learn more about the
remarkable Hillsdale College which I
don't know enough about I have a junior
in high school who's shopping for
colleges so I'm going to do a little due
diligence on hillsdale for him I
appreciate the invitation to come to
speak today about this issue of
accountability for the financial crisis
of 2008 that we're still really trying
to dig our way out of it's something
that I think few people would have
predicted that for 25 years after the
events of 2007 and 2008 that we're still
really trying to understand what
happened who did it why and how just
going back in time a little bit as
Bailey mentioned I was at Forbes
magazine for many years before I joined
the new york times and one of the joys
of my job there was that i could write
about companies doing the right thing as
well as companies doing the wrong thing
well since i joined the times in May of
98 it really has felt to me like it's
been all scandal all the time first we
had the long-term capital management
hedge fund debacle we've had the
Internet bubble we've had accounting
scandals and Ron worldcom etc booms and
busts currency crises bank failures it's
really just been an amazing 14 years and
I've had a ringside seat for all of it
nevertheless I did feel that the
material that was thrown at me and other
financial journalists in the years
leading up to the crisis and the
aftermath made all the previous crises
seem like child's play so now I feel
like I'm almost an archaeologist at a
historic site still digging uncovering
shocking and really overwhelming
evidence of deeply unethical activities
that flourished during the mortgage
mania simply put the amount of lying and
cheating that went on during the years
leading up to the crisis is almost
unimaginable and I'm not sure that we
even know all of it yet first of course
we had lenders who made loans to
borrowers that could not repay them the
loans carried enormous fees and profits
for the lenders who then sold them to
Wall Street then the executives at these
firms did their parts by putting toxic
loans into mortgage securities that were
sold to unsuspecting investors those who
bought the securities were told that the
loans were high quality and met certain
standards this was not true when these
loans failed the only recourse that
these investors had was to sue the firms
that sold the securities then of course
there were the ratings agencies who
according to some who dealt directly
with them knew that the loans were
questionable but assigned high grades to
the securities that held them anyway the
money generated by rating these complex
securities was just too compelling of
course borrowers played
part desperate to get in on the rising
real estate market they were only too
happy to fib about their income or their
financial positions their lies also
contributed to the mess while these
scandalous activities were going on
financial regulators the very people
charged with identifying and eliminating
problematic practices were cheering on
the miscreants even after danger signs
relating to the credit mania had become
obvious officials at most regulatory
agencies seemed bent on protecting the
very quote financial innovation that had
fueled the crisis they recoiled at
blocking complex and exotic mortgage
products on the grounds that they could
increase the benefits of home ownership
a goal that was claimed to be a win-win
for everyone and they rhapsodize about
the marvels of derivatives and how they
spread risk rather than concentrated it
so looking back that was a whole lot of
bad stuff going on but those were just
the practices during the boom years
since then during the bust we've had a
raft of bad behavior dubious practices
surrounding the foreclosure crisis for
example representatives of banks in
their haste to drum troubled borrowers
out of their homes forged legal
documents filed phony papers with the
courts and floated hundreds of years of
property law taken together during the
boom and the bust I would argue that
this is a breathtaking series of ethical
breakdowns and compliance failures and
it led to one of the most shattering
financial crises in our history but
importantly it has also generated deep
questions about whether our country and
those
it's upper echelon of both business and
government have lost their moral compass
populists capitalism like our system is
hugely beneficial to the vast majority
of people but an ethical tradition is
needed for it to work when you have
senior executives walking away with
hundreds of millions of dollars leaving
shareholders and innocent taxpayers
holding the bag it becomes extremely
dangerous and as more and more jobs
disappear across the country the
outsized pay amassed by corporate
executives and Wall Street traders
becomes even more polarizing this is
especially so when taxpayers are asked
to bail out reckless companies now the
question that remains to be answered and
that will have to be tackled by
ethicists far better qualified than I is
why did greed and unethical behavior go
so viral during this recent period I
think one bit of an explanation lies in
a rejection by some business leaders of
a very powerful social compact that many
of their predecessors had it once
embraced that is a duty to others rather
than simply to self according to this
compact in its ideal people in positions
of power recognized that they had
immense sway over investors workers and
customers and they agreed to hold
themselves to a higher standard of care
as a result it was an unwritten rule
perhaps but now it seems to have been
supplanted by the notion that personal
profits are supreme and that making it
to the top and gaining respect from
society means having the largest bank
account
we also I think importantly seem
entrenched in a system where a moral
behavior is condoned because it is not
per se illegal instead of asking if a
deal is appropriate for everyone
involved and doing the age-old gut check
of wondering whether you'd cringe if the
deals details were laid out on the front
page of the New York Times executives
and their advisors today seemed to view
their actions much more narrowly if you
can muster an argument that what you're
doing is highly profitable and not
outright illegal then go for it who
cares if it's immoral or wrong or hurts
people I have on my desk at work an old
new yorker cartoon that sums this up in
it or a group of executives seated in a
boardroom the man at the head of the
table is saying quote remember it's not
a lie if it makes us money lies that
made some people a lot of money were a
crucial element of the credit crisis
mortgage brokers selling loans to
customers who didn't understand them
Wall Street firms peddling securities to
clients who were not told of their
faulty structures ratings agencies
slapping high grades on securities they
didn't understand or hadn't scrutinized
and very few of these participants have
been held accountable for their
deceptions indeed these players continue
to argue to anyone who will listen that
their customers come first and that
their due diligence is strong these
arguments are stunningly disconnected
from reality Nobel prize-winning
economist Joseph Stiglitz sum things up
pretty well when he said America's
financial players created risk miss
allocated capital and encouraged
excessive indebtedness all while
imposing high
transaction costs and they brought our
entire economy to the brink but to this
day we hear regulators and of course
those in the industry extolling the
praises of financial innovation and yet
many of the innovations that were
roundly praised in the years leading up
to the crisis did contribute mightily to
its depth and damage credit default
swaps and collateralized debt
obligations are two perfect examples
these products amplified expanded the
mortgage meltdown and its losses this is
not what financial innovation should
create true financial innovation should
help society not hurt it rather than
raising investors and borrowers risks
through obscure and hard to fathom
investments in instruments financial
innovation should have helped these
people mitigate the risks of
homeownership but instead they helped a
small band of industry participants
profit at the expense of the rest of us
in spite of this we continue to hear
from bankers that tighter regulation of
the financial sector will [ __ ] their
innovative tendencies indeed these
institutions their executives and
lobbyists continue to resist significant
regulation designed to prevent taxpayers
from having to bail out any of their
companies in the future now this failure
to admit culpability is bad enough but
it has also been worsened exacerbated by
an even more disturbing failure by the
government to assign responsibility for
this mess holding people who were
central to the crisis accountable for
their roles in it has seemed just too
difficult for our government
regulators and prosecutors to do let's
consider the case of angelo mozilo the
former chief executive of Countrywide
Financial once one of the nation's
largest subprime lenders he was sued by
the SEC in 2009 for insider trading
because the regulator's alleged he had
publicly pronounced his company healthy
while privately derided the quality of
the mortgages countrywide was writing
using words like toxic and poison in
internal emails mr. Mozilo seemed to
understand well the risks that his
company was taking in the subprime
mortgage boom but publicly meanwhile he
maintained that his company was first
class and financially sound all the
while he was selling shares that he had
received as compensation while running
countrywide in fact he sold 500 million
dollars worth of stock over several
years time as the subprime crisis was
approaching the SEC said that he sold
these shares improperly because he knew
the dangers that were facing his company
and yet a year later in 2010 the SEC
struck a settlement deal with Mozilla
requiring him to pay just 22.5 million
dollars to end the case that's 22.5
million against 500 million in stock
sales that's a pretty good trade I think
most of us would take that meanwhile the
rest of the fines that were levied by
the SEC 45.5 million dollars were paid
by Bank of America or its insurers so
what's the lesson that we can all take
away from this example get while the
getting is good and if you get nabbed
well you'll probably be able to get off
for pennies on the dollar
during the financial crisis in fact it
seems that we've been all too happy to
lower the bar for what constitutes bad
behavior instead one of the indeed one
of the arguments for why there have not
been more criminal prosecutions
following the debacle is that the
actions taken by people in positions of
power were not technically illegal it
certainly wasn't right or proper for the
head of a large financial institution
not to understand the risks that his
underlings were taking to make their
sumptuous bonuses but was it illegal
perhaps not and that's why some people
say we have seen no prosecutions of
those who marched Bear Stearns Lehman
Brothers countrywide and Merrill Lynch
off the cliff neither was it correct or
proper to sell a mortgage security to
customers that had been designed to fail
but was it illegal the investment banks
who sold such things have argued that
they disclosed all the necessary details
in the boilerplate of the prospectuses
so they maintained they did not run
afoul of securities laws not long ago
Eric Holder the head of the Justice
Department made such a distinction in a
speech at Columbia University Law School
he said their quote much of the conduct
that led to the financial crisis was
unethical and irresponsible but we also
have discovered that some of the
behavior while morally reprehensible may
not necessarily have been criminal and
quote there he is explaining what
everyone wants to know why there have
not been more criminal prosecutions it's
hard I think for many people to accept
this argument it's just too hard to
believe that a financial debacle so
large and so destructive as this one
did not involve any criminal activity I
certainly and the first to say that I am
NOT a prosecutor but that i do
understand well how difficult it is to
mount a criminal case but because so
many people have been hurt by the
destructive activities and their
outcomes it's incredibly disturbing for
many to see leaders of American
corporations amid this mess walk away
from the wreckage pretty much unscathed
yes they've suffered losses in their
stock holdings and many are facing
private litigation but the damage that
they and others like them have done to
innocent taxpayers borrowers and
shareholders is nothing short of Titanic
these wrecking crews appear to have paid
little for their transgressions the
trouble is if prosecutors don't pursue a
wide array of illegal activities then
you wind up encouraging more of the very
destructive behavior by not punishing
these practices quickly firmly and
forcefully you incentivize the
miscreants to push the envelope even
further the next time if there's no
penalty for illegality than there
certainly is none for a morality of
course again it's hard to mount criminal
cases but at last count only one
relatively high level mortgage banking
official had been sentenced to jail time
in a case arising out of the meltdown
his name was Lee Farkas and he led a
three billion dollar fraud running a
lender called Taylor bean and Whitaker
he was sentenced to 30 years in prison
all well and good but Taylor bean and
leaf arcus were certainly not at the
center of the financial crisis
it is possible of course that additional
indictments and prison sentences will be
forthcoming but the fact that so few
people have been held accountable for
this particular mess by the spring 2012
makes some people wonder if there's
something more pernicious at work
perhaps a concerted effort to protect
some of the primary participants from
prosecution this is not an idle question
given that so many high-powered players
were involved in the questionable
practices that led to the crisis many
hailing from Wall Street and Washington
digging too deeply into the mess could
touch some mighty participants one might
we'll ask whether the government really
wants to identify who did what to whom
during this episode with regulators at
the Federal Reserve the office of Thrift
Supervision the Comptroller of the
currency and the SEC so involved in
allowing the bad practices leading up to
the crisis to go on you would wonder
whether a hard-nosed government
investigator might not wind up probing
himself or his colleagues it's my belief
that many people in Washington know that
if they launched a full-blown
investigation of the meltdown the
spotlight might soon come to their door
I think it's really important to point
out that our current situation with zero
prosecutions stands in stark contrast to
what went on during the SNL crisis of
the late 80s and early 90s that was a
period when hundreds of banks failed but
in the wake of that mess special
government task forces referred 1,100
cases to prosecutors resulting in more
than 800 bank officials going to jail
many of these people were chief
executives not lower level flunkies
among the best known
Charles Keating CEO of Lincoln Savings
and Loan in Arizona and David Paul head
of centrist bank in Florida here's
another data point that I find
interesting because of its contrast to
today in the early 1990s President Bush
made it clear that ferreting out fraud
at the SNL's was a top priority of his
administration he directed the Justice
Department to make these cases with
vigor if we fast-forward to the current
crisis we find the opposite approach in
the spring of 2008 just as the storm was
gathering the FBI scaled back plans to
assign more field agents to investigate
mortgage fraud that summer just weeks
before the collapse of Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac Lehman and AIG the
Department of Justice also rejected
calls to create a task force devoted to
mortgage related investigations leaving
these complex cases understaffed and
poorly funded only much later did the
Justice Department establish a more
general Financial Crimes Task Force why
have there been so few prosecutions that
succeeded out of this mess some of the
prosecutors that I've spoken to in my
reporting argue that the types of fraud
perpetrated during the S&L crisis were
easier to litigate those cases were
characterized by embezzlement
self-dealing and other bad behavior that
was more easily identified and exposed
well we do know that Wall Street likes
to create complexity and there's no
doubt that the Securities involved in
this debacle were far more convoluted
and impenetrable for investigators to
plumb but I think add more interesting
reason for the failure to prosecute lies
with lies in an answer I've been given
by some Prosecco
it brings us right back to the colossal
regulatory failure that fueled the
crisis we all know regulators decline to
rein in dubious practices in the boom
years but the failure had dire
consequences in addition to the millions
of borrowers who were hurt and investors
and taxpayers this regulatory in
competence prosecutors argued to me led
to a lack of prosecutions in the
aftermath of the bubble that's because
so many of the overseers failed in their
duties to compile the kinds of
information that traditionally is used
to build successful criminal cases so in
effect the same dynamic that helped
enable the crisis weak regulation asleep
at the switch regulators also made it
harder to pursue fraud in its aftermath
let's go back to the SNL crisis to talk
about how important regulatory referrals
are two successful prosecutions in that
period the FBI opened 5500 criminal
investigations using regulatory
referrals and again as I mentioned a
moment ago by 1992 there had been 1,100
criminal prosecutions of major bank
fraud resulting in 839 convictions a
more aggressive mindset among regulators
could certainly have spurred more
prosecutions this time around according
to officials who were involved in the
SNL clean up one of them is William
black a professor of law at the
University of Missouri in Kansas City he
was the federal government's director of
litigation during the S&L crisis and he
told me that the relaxed regulatory
approach in the current episode quote
created an exceptional criminogenic
environment there were no criminal
referrals from regulators no fraud
working groups no national task force no
effective punishment he said instead
we've had pretty much silence from the
highest levels of government Michael
Mukasey a former federal judge in New
York who had been headed the Justice
Department less than a year when Bear
Stearns failed disgust at that time
setting up a task force with deputies
but decided against it announcing the
decision in June of 2008 now there have
been some attempts to put money into
investigations for example two years
into the crisis Congress passed the
fraud enforcement and Recovery Act
allocating 165 million dollars to the
Justice Department and FBI for new
financial crisis cases but Congress
quietly took away all but 30 million of
that allocation later so put all of
these actions or inactions together and
I think you can see how this has
contributed to our current and
frustrating situation where participants
in one of the biggest economic disasters
in history seem to have skated away from
the scene untouched equally disturbing
the failure to put resources into law
enforcement on these cases confirms a
dangerous suspicion that many Americans
hold that is that there are two sets of
rules in our nation one for Washington
and the powerful companies that
contribute to their re-election
campaigns and one for the rest of us
even when the security is the top
securities cops at the SEC have a clear
standard to pursue executives under
sarbanes-oxley they come up decidedly
short after the grand frauds at enron
worldcom in adelphia Congress set out to
hold executives accountable if their
companies cooked the books under the
sarbanes-oxley Act of 2002 the
SEC was encouraged to hit executives
where it hurts in the wallet if they
certified financial results that turned
out to be bogus SAR box was supposed to
keep managers honest they would have to
hand back exec incentive pay like
bonuses even if they themselves did not
fudge the accounts that was the idea
anyway but the record suggests a bark
decidedly worse than bite the SEC
brought its first case under Section 304
of SAR box in 2007 by late 2011 it had
filed cases demanding that only 31
executives at 20 companies returned some
pay in 2007 and ate most of the cases
involved shenanigans relating to stock
options and produced some big recoveries
for the SEC but in the wake of the
financial crisis the dollars recouped
have amounted to an asterisk from the
beginning of 2009 through 2011 the SEC
pursued 18 executives at 10 companies it
has recovered a total of twelve point
two million dollars from nine former
executives other cases are pending half
of the companies pursued by the SEC
during the past three years have been
small and relatively obscure for those
interested in accountability in the
mortgage crisis a clawback case brought
by the SEC against new century financial
now defunct but one of the most
aggressive mortgage lenders out there is
a severe disappointment Michael missile
a partner at the law firm of K&L gates
and the bankruptcy examiner hired to
investigate new century uncovered seven
different types of accounting fraud he
said that fattened the pay of the
company's top executives in 2005 and 6
during those years he found brad morris
the
company's chief executive collected 2.9
million dollars in incentive pay but
when the SEC brought its claw back case
it considered a much narrower series of
accounting irregularities and recovered
only five hundred and forty-two thousand
dollars from mr. Morris never mind that
as mr. missile the examiner told me
quote I found many serious violations in
the investigation and laid them out as
clearly as possible with all the
supporting information how assiduously
the SEC brings these cases could not be
more important that's because only the
SEC can bring cases under Section 304
companies can't and neither can
shareholders but even when it does crack
down on wrongdoers the SEC does little
to discourage them from becoming
recidivists according to a new york
times analysis by my colleague ed Wyatt
nearly all of the biggest financial
companies in the nation Goldman Sachs
Morgan Stanley JPMorgan Chase and Bank
of America among them have settled fraud
cases by promising that they would never
again violate an anti-fraud law and yet
all of these companies were found by the
SEC to have done just that a few years
after they made their promises The Times
analysis of enforcement actions during
the past 15 years found at least 51
cases in which the SEC concluded that
Wall Street firms had broken anti-fraud
laws that they had agreed never to
breach the 51 cases spanned 19 different
companies and yet in the face of this
recidivism the Commission has not
brought any contempt charges against
large financial firms in the last 10
years I think when we consider these
facts
it shouldn't come as a surprise that
trust in our nation's institutions both
public and private have been decimated
as a result of the crisis and it's
aftermath the credit crisis was a
two-pronged failure after all first the
failure by the private sector to rain
itself in or to limit itself to
appropriate business practices in some
cases but second was the abysmal
regulatory performance the failure by
people at the highest levels of our
financial system to understand the risky
practices being pursued by some of the
nation's largest banks was nothing short
of breathtaking this inability or
refusal to recognize peril when it was
staring them in the face meant that Ben
Bernanke and his regulatory colleagues
were far behind when the subprime crisis
began to metastasize it seems pretty
clear to me into a lot of the readers
that I hear from that many people in
positions of power seem to have lost
their sense of duty and obligation to
others there is a decidedly me first
approach that dominates today I don't
know how to force people in high places
to forego profits for propriety I do
know that those of us in the media can
help by shining light on the dark
corners where such practices often
flourish still to regain confidence
after enduring this mess I believe that
at least some of the people who blew up
these institutions must be held
accountable for their actions investors
pensioners employees and taxpayers all
have been hurt by reckless risk-taking
at the highest level of some of these
companies it will be beyond exasperated
the people who created this disaster and
profited mightily from it are allowed to
slink off into the night I'd like to
close with a quote from Frederic Bastiat
a 19th century economist and writer that
seems especially on point he said the
following when plunder becomes a way of
life for a group of men living together
in society they create for themselves in
the course of time a legal system that
authorizes it and a moral code that
glorifies it that's what we are all up
against and we must not allow it to
prevail thank you very much for your
attention I'd be very happy to take
questions from the audience
this person's hand shot right up my name
is my name is Bruce Bennett I'm locally
here in Vienna Virginia one question i
have is had we let the bass fail and not
not a bail amount with the country of
christ as they people said it would or
would we have had a better stronger
financial system of those people out if
the banks have been allowed to fail
would we be in a better position now
because or we would be have fallen off
the cliffs in the financial system you
know very difficult question to answer
i'll answer in two parts one is that the
way that i would have liked to have seen
this crisis played out if i could go and
restart the movie and start the real
running again would be for the
government to allow bear stearns to fail
in march of 2008 because Bear Stearns
was a smallish firm it was extremely
heavily into mortgages so sort of had
made its bed taking great risks taken
immense profits in this area you know I
think that the fact that the Federal
Reserve pushed JPMorgan Chase into the
shotgun wedding with Bear Stearns sent a
very pernicious message to the markets
to the financial firms which was that
you'll get help you'll get salvaged
you'll get bailed out you'll you don't
have to pay the price of failure I think
their Stern's would have been a less
damaging failure if it had been allowed
then Lehman was which was a larger firm
with more interconnections I think so if
I were to you know want to go back in
time and change how things were done I
would like to see what happened if Bear
Stearns were allowed to fail I think if
it were allowed to fail people would
have gotten the message pretty quick
that you better get your house in order
and remember there was a six-month
period after Bear Stearns failed in
which really very little happened it was
a calm before the storm of September
2008 when we had this non-stop failures
Fannie Freddie Lehman AIG so there was a
six-month window of opportunity there
that I think could have been used to be
be much more aggressive about getting
down assets on balance sheets taking
leverage down if possible so that's one
answer to your question and the other
answer that I would say is we just have
to get to a position where these large
firms are not so interconnected that
they can actually make the argument that
if they fail they could bring down the
financial system it is clear to me that
everybody who was running the country
then believed that if they were allowed
to fail that they would bring down the
financial system and when you talk to
people about Lehman Brothers they felt
that that was the lesson from Lehman the
failure the money market funds etc that
that was clear you can't let these
things fail so the reaction to me should
be how can we get these banks
institutions brokerage firms whatever
down to a size that's manageable and
that won't imperil the entire financial
system if they take too many risks we
have gotten nowhere with that kind of an
approach and that's unfortunate yes
ramon bueller with the madison coalition
i noticed that there were two groups
that you did not explicitly discuss in
your analysis one are the elected
politicians who empowered fannie and
freddie to borrow all these and it
that's a week long discussion and and
who of course then spend taxpayer money
to bail all these folks out and who then
if you look at barney frank and chris
dodd who were both deeply involved in
the process authored a bill allegedly to
solve the problem and the other group
was you didn't mention the business
media and one of the things we count on
is when politicians miss behave as they
generically do and when the private
sector prioritizes profit and bends the
rules as sometimes happens shouldn't we
actually blame the business media for
not blowing the whistle on some of these
activities out way before they did
certainly agree with both of your themes
the role of legislators cannot be
minimized but again it is a an
enormously long conversation I did
tackle it in my book reckless
endangerment with my co-author Josh
rosner and you know we were quite I
think unsparing with the details on just
how how Fannie Mae really was the kind
of leader in teaching companies how to
co-opt Congress how to neutralize their
regulator and how to make sure that they
were able to make all the decisions
about things like regulatory capital and
you know their business model and
meanwhile get rich while they're doing
it so yes that's a huge topic and one
that has also not been addressed in any
meaningful way after the crisis as far
as the business media I certainly would
agree that they did not do we did not do
as good a job as we should have in the
years leading up to the car
faces I think there may be a couple of
reasons for that first is a kind of
mindset that you have to have I'm a
tough reporter and I like being a tough
reporter but it's hard you have to have
a backbone you have to have an editor
who's willing to stand up against the
pressures which are immense and you have
to have a different mindset you don't
want to be a part of the party you don't
want to be invited to the people's
houses who you cover you don't want to
be feeling like you're part of that
scene and there are a lot of journalists
who unfortunately get sucked into the
idea that they can be friends with the
people that they're covering I don't do
that kind of journalism but I think that
it's unfortunate that there are quite a
few who do now I will also say though
that newsrooms have been devastated by
the internet and the creative
destruction that the internet has
brought to the newspaper business and so
you will have far fewer newsrooms who
have local reporters covering local you
know scandals far fewer reporters
covering business far fewer reporters
covering everything because the numbers
just don't work anymore the the revenues
are just not there and so you have to
lay people off so I think that's an
element that has to be recognized also I
did raise red flags very early on in two
thousand 2005 when Fannie Mae had their
accounting scandal talked about mortgage
crisis talked about credit default swaps
very early on so I know what you have to
take from people when you take these
large institutions on and it's not fun
but if you want to try to educate expose
the truth that's what journalists are
supposed to do I am a firm believer that
that's you know the the standard that we
should hold ourselves to I just wish
there were more people that I could
consider in the same bailiwick but their
new kids coming up all the time and I'm
hopeful that you know maybe we can
change that dynamic
we actually have a question from an
online viewer on ax from Houston Texas
and she asks you have called for greater
criminal prosecution against the
perpetrators of the financial crisis yet
you have also noted that their actions
were immoral rather than illegal if this
is so how would criminal charges be just
considering they broke no laws well
again this is the question of did they
break no laws and you know not being a
prosecutor and not knowing not having
all the facts at my disposal I'm just
unaware i can't make the conclusion that
there was broad swaths of illegality
here however i do think it's hard to
imagine that you can't bring some cases
even for regulators to bring cases under
sarbanes-oxley so I think the degree to
which there has been so little
regulatory or criminal prosecutions just
sends a bad signal you know the case i
mentioned with angelo mozilo seems to be
a prime example of sort of walking away
from what looked like you know a pretty
fact oriented fact-based case again
perhaps Eric Holder is right perhaps
there was no illegal activity but I
don't think I think that that's a
perception that people don't support
because I think early on my reporting
and my colleagues reporting shows that
early on there was a sense at the
highest levels in Washington that we
shouldn't pursue these institutions
until we got on a firmer financial
footing there was a sense that we didn't
want to aggressively pursue prosecutions
while we were still trying to find our
way in the dire months of 2008 2009 and
I think that led to a sort of a lacks
approach to the idea of prosecuting some
of these cases and of course we have
time limits and we have all kinds of
statutes of limitations that are running
on these cases whether we're talking
civil or
criminals so there's a real danger i
think in saying let's not do anything
right now until things settle down and
get more calm the danger is that you let
precious hours go by weeks months and
precious data and information that you
need to have to make a case go by but i
think that what Professor black has told
me and other prosecutors is that there
certainly were civil cases that were not
made there certainly were regulatory
cases that were not made strongly enough
and even if those had been made I think
you'd have a different perception out
there about accountability than we have
today yes wait wait for your microphone
we're talking about the pride the
corporation and I'd like your thoughts
on this corporations executives are
supposed to be responsible for that to
the directors who in turn are
responsible to the stockholders the
truth is the directors are often picked
by the gym they socialized the night
before the meeting they and their
spouses have dinner and the next day the
director is expected to look them in the
eye and say bill you're overpaid which
is very hard to do right behind that is
the stockholder who's supposed to be
able to vote the rascals out the truth
is i can buy a stock on the phone right
now and sell it in 10 minutes so i have
no incentive to stand and fight is
anyone thought about some way to inject
the true scrutiny in the corporate
process that just isn't there right now
is that have you ever heard it brought
up a discussed by anybody I've certainly
heard the question brought up which is
why don't we have more aggressive
shareholder activism or even just
policing shareholder policing of boards
because there is the sense and I think
it's absolutely accurate that boards are
cronies of the
management and that they're yes men and
women and that you know maybe they are
there to justify what their decisions
are but in any case CEO pay keeps
ratcheting up very few people held
accountable when there are disasters you
know that are uncovered so you know one
of my biggest one of the things I think
is the biggest dysfunction in the system
right now is something you're alluding
to which is the failure of large
institutions that run your money my
money to hold these people accountable
and hold their feet to the fire I mean
if I own a hundred shares of Exxon and I
vote against the pay package that's not
going to have any impact whatsoever if
I'm fidelity and I'm you know voting
shares that are held on behalf of
thousands millions of people across the
country you're going to have a lot more
clout but these companies do not really
take this on as a goal or as a purpose
and I find that to be very disturbing
they're running other people's money and
yet they're not acting responsibly in
holding boards accountable and holding
boards accountable is really the only
way that you can start to get to the
point where you can hold the executives
accountable now we have seen this year a
little bit more action on pay practices
we've seen some pay compensation deals
that were rejected by a majority of the
shareholders that's very unusual that
seems like it's a start in an idea of
being you know shareholders expressing
their views but it is a slow slow
process and if we don't have the help of
the people who are managing our money
for us if fidelity or Vanguard or name
your fund company doesn't want to rock
the boat perhaps because they have other
dealings with the companies who shares
they own then that's a problem and that
contributes to the sort of lace a fair
board approach that
think is common at so many companies so
you know one person said to me they
thought that maybe social media could be
a way to get shareholders together to
act as a group that would be great that
would be a great outcome of of social
media but I haven't seen it yet and
again this is a glacial process to even
get shareholders to vote against
munificent pay packages so I'm as
frustrated as you are Washington's
response to the financial debacle was an
act Minh of the dodd-frank legislation
now the dodd-frank law what is your
assessment of that statutes potential to
keep such debacles from happening in the
future I guess another way of putting
that is did Congress know what he was
doing when it was passing that and did
Obama know what he was doing what he
what he signed it thank you I think the
dodd-frank law was a its 2,000 pages of
you know impenetrable complex details
that really end up not protecting us
anywhere you know it may be even not
protecting us a bit more than we were
leading up to the crisis um I I like to
compare it to glass-steagall
glass-steagall was 34 pages long
dodd-frank is 2,000 pages long
glass-steagall protected us for about 70
years I don't think that Frank's going
to protect us for even 10 I think that
the key there he failures in dodd-frank
first of all they did nothing they were
silent on fannie mae and freddie mac
didn't have the you know the spine to go
after that second of all they did
nothing about too big to fail now you
know Dodd and Frank will say oh yes we
did we've put together these um what do
they call resolution authority there's
the resolution authority that's going to
allow a
unwind of a threatening institution if
it's too big and too large and too
politically are interconnected or if
it's on the precipice we will unwind
this through the resolution authority
but the problem with the resolution
authority is that it requires the
committee the F sock it's called to vote
to in fact resolve and unwind the
institution and I think that that is a
step that many many people would not
choose to take it would again be a
moment just as the moments that faced
Geithner and Paulson in 2008 which was
it's easier just to bail it out it's
easier just to make the taxpayers pay
and then deal with it later than it is
to make the hard decisions to let a firm
get unwound and these are very large and
powerful firms that have a lot of
friends in Washington so I I am just
very dubious that the resolution
authority is going to work as well as
Dodd and Frank seemed to think that it
will in resolving large interconnected
institutions so I think there were a lot
of failures there were some good things
about dodd-frank but for the 2,000 pages
of whatever you know I just don't think
it's put us that much closer to a period
where the taxpayers can sleep at night
without worrying about having to bail
out companies in the future yes
thank you very much my name is Tyler
O'Neill recent Hillsdale graduate and
aspiring journalists oh really good for
you jump one that's the idea okay my
question is regarding the idea of
regulations and holding these businesses
accountable President Wilson famously
argued that the economy had become so
complicated that we needed a bigger
government to rein in excesses and yet
we see a movement like the tea party
that wants smaller government smaller
regulations and it seems that you're
talking almost both sides of the
spectrum that it would be better if we
hadn't bailed out these businesses and
just let them fall apart from their own
bad practices but at the same time you
want to hold people accountable
responsible and we need more
administration to do that so I think
letting them fail would hold them
accountable right I mean to some degree
right if they failed then that would be
the first step to accountability but no
you're right you know it's it's a fine
line I think to walk you can't you can't
have zero regulation and you can't have
too much regulation so how where is the
happy medium now I have never made the
argument that there was not enough
regulation on the mortgage industry or
financial services industry going in the
years leading up to the crisis there
were plenty of rules on the books that
the regulator's just did not pursue and
so what I would say the answer is is to
have people in these jobs that have an
appetite to regulate and have an
appetite to really go after the problems
that they see but there becomes this
mindset in the regulatory community
where you're kind of a partner with the
entity that you're overseeing your
you've got the same you know kind of
brain meld as it were almost with the
bankers that you're dealing with in fact
many of the regulator's in the years
leading up to the crisis were believing
that the banks had the answer on their
risk assessments and could be allowed to
present regulators with their own
assessments of risks on their books and
let regulators sort of work
with that instead of the regulator being
the person who's sort of the watchdog or
policemen so I think that there were
rules that were completely ignored by
regulators and years leading up with the
crisis so I don't feel that we needed
way more regulation at all we just
needed people with an appetite to
regulate which we did not we did not
have in fact they were many cases you
know partnering with institutions the
idea of reducing capital requirements
and reducing those kinds of standards so
that was I think a disappointing element
at work so it's not more regulation is
not the answer because you have to have
people who are willing to actually
regulate one of the in my in the book
that Josh and I wrote reckless
endangerment we had a conversation with
Barney Frank when we were asking him
about his undying support for fannie mae
and he had been it particularly
difficult and particularly obstreperous
with the regulator that was put in place
in the mid-90s to try to beef up
regulation on fannie and he would you
know he was tough in congressional
hearings he would you know rail really
made it made life difficult for this
regulator and so we asked him what was
the idea of being so hard on this guy's
just trying to do his job and he said I
felt that they were trying to be too
adversarial and I said well hmm
adversarial accra serial kind of sounds
like a good thing for a regular
regulator to be no no no they were too
adversarial that's not the right ideal
for a regular so you know it's almost
like a journalist I mean people who I
write about who don't like what I right
call me adversarial but you know I am
NOT a part of their corporate spin well
a regulator should not be a part of the
spin of the institution they're
regulating so I thought that was a very
interesting comment that he made which
revealed a lot about the regulatory
community and in and how it is you know
viewed and
seen by members of Congress who oversee
these people so that was kind of an
eye-opener for me you know but I would
argue for a more adversarial
relationship than less each time for one
more question this person's been very
very patient here here you go so I don't
see any hope for oh don't feel actual
things happening regulators everyone
what do you think is the ultimate answer
the ultimate answer to getting us out of
this boom-bust bailout cycle illegal or
immoral actions on the part of
government and businesses I think again
I think we just have to see a few cases
it wouldn't take a lot of cases it
wouldn't take hundreds of cases it would
take maybe one prosecutor who's trying
to make his or her Spurs to you know
make people sit up and take notice but
again I think it's a multi-faceted
question it goes to the question about
boards and it goes to the question of
investors and so you know it's it's
massive and so there are a lot of
failings at every step of the way so
what can we do as individuals to try to
change this dynamic this is the toughest
question I get and I'm very disappointed
to say that I don't have a ready answer
because it does feel like individuals
are powerless it does feel like
individuals have no voice and are
particularly up against you know ever
increasing power on the other side of
some of these very important issues so
I'm not without hope but I think that
the idea is that people have to take
some of this on themselves and whether
it's you know complaining to your fund
company if you don't like the way they
vote your shares voting no against
excessive pay at companies even if you
only have ten shares I mean it's a
message that you can send but it really
is
I agree with you said there is a sense
that it's not going to get a lot of
traction and that's unfortunate because
we're ultimately the people who are
paying the price thank you very much for
your time
thank you very much and thank you all
for coming today I will close with one
announcement that Todd later this week
you all are welcome to join us for
friday evening reception and talk
professor stephen smith Hillsdale
College English professor will be
speaking on the topic becoming a
statesman ten councils from Thomas More
you're all welcome to join us as we
welcome the hillsdale college students
who are here for the summer professor
Smith will engage that topic also we
have lunch available for you today lunch
is served on the first floor you may eat
anywhere throughout the building that's
open including the fourth floor terrace
and thank you